Yellowstone star's mission to support
the children of fallen heroes we're
talking about Cole Hauser better known
to many people as Rip wheeler the rugged
anti-hero on the hit series Yellowstone
on Paramount right now part of the same
company as CBS that's a coincidence this
Memorial Day weekend though you're going
to learn a new side of him Catherine
Herridge introduces us to his quest to
help kids who have lost parents help
those kids realize their dreams
his Yellowstone character rip wheeler is
the quintessential cowboy
ruthless you want to fight somebody you
come fight me and loyal to a fault or
your family it's a world away from Cole
Hauser's personal passion this
organization is changing the lives of
these young men and women
his involvement with the Special
Operations Warrior Foundation which
gives educational scholarships to
Children of Fallen service members you
could attach yourself to almost any
charity why Special Operations I'm a big
fan of second chances for kids when they
lose a family member this is a huge loss
for them the charity has awarded 1100
scholarships maybe it's just my way of
you know serving
you know this country the soldiers
um their families that quiet service
that began two decades ago includes a
USO tour in Afghanistan and Hauser told
us about his private visits to Walter
Reed Medical Center there was about four
or five guys that that I stayed in touch
with for for many many years some have
committed suicide unfortunately some are
still alive and doing well it was a very
kind of educational time for me as a
young man in my 20s bobcats look good
Hauser's down to earth style a quality
he shares with his Yellowstone character
helped him connect with severely wounded
service members including one triple
amputee I walked in and I go God you
look like a rat's ass but it got him to
smile you know and then we would start
talking and it was just you know it
break the ice Hauser sits on the
Charities board of directors and worked
with the foundation's President Clay
hutmacher to expand scholarships to
Special Operations families who lose a
non military parent when they're
calculating what they're going to do in
the future funding of their children's
education is not part of that equation
retired Green Beret Lou houck's two
children are among the first recipients
as Houck deployed overseas he and his
wife Sydney used his military tuition
assistance money to finance her dream of
becoming a midwife she had a passion for
helping you know women like her and
helping their babies I was super super
proud of her shortly after graduation
Sydney was diagnosed with an incurable
cancer when Sydney died hunk became a
single dad with no savings for college
then the foundation stepped in what does
it mean to have that burden lifted
honestly it feels like love to have an
organization
and supporters that care about
children and their future whom they've
never met
I mean
it's love
It's like got to be a thousand pounds
off your back you know think about that
Hauser's mission to ease the burden on
military families began with this ring
gifted to him by his late grandfather
Milton Sperling a World War II Marine a
Hollywood producer and screenwriter he
wants to carry on that Legacy through
his own children bringing that
unwavering rip wheeler loyalty to the
Next Generation I think it's as good as
it gets the human element of wanting to
help just to see somebody go through
that moment of of like Grace it's like
ah
Hazard said he is excited about the
future of the foundation how it's
bringing awareness to these surviving
children and reminding all of us for the
service of these military families makes
our freedoms possible
such an amazing car yeah that he's
getting involved with it and and you
know for him to have this stage using
his influence in a way that he's doing
it says more about him as a man than it
does about him as an actor yeah well you
know the thing that I found is that
there's the actor Rick wheeler and then
there's the person Cole Hauser and he's
got a lot of compassion and a lot of
empathy and an ability to really connect
with these service members and he can
see what I know as someone in a military
family that it's everyone who serves
it's the spouse it's the children so
these scholarships really acknowledge
and recognize that service it's such a
great point and I love the way the
recipient described it as feeling like
love yeah you know through all of it
like it's love it's relief that's what
family does for for family it's
relief and
um Lou Houck told us this Memorial Day
the way that we can all really recognize
this service and the people that we've
lost he said you know when you do this
work you lose a lot of people say grief
is a roller coaster but you can
acknowledge their service by living the
life they would want you to leave and to
really make the most of those freedoms
that are possible that's good beautiful
words beautiful report Catherine thank
you very much